that's kind of bleeding onto my question
and I'm a young entrepreneur and I and
you know I've done some pretty
interesting stuff over the last two
years and I'm currently writing a bit
about my experiences what I've done one
when I when I've got it finished how how
would you suggest I go about it I've got
a bit of a networking a bit the
following do I self publish it do I go
and find someone who wants to hook up
and help sell it or what what do you
reckon
how publishing is becoming a bigger and
bigger option for me the reason I don't
self publish is when I sign my book
deals the cash flow matters to me
because I'm able to do something with
that money so if you're able to get
seven-figure advance you know you do
that even six-figure advances because
you can get a lot of value out of that
upfront cash on the flip side you're
sharing revenue with a publisher that's
oftentimes not gonna bring as much value
from the marketing and selling
standpoint so those are just decisions
you make in moments in time
self-publishing you know the kind of a
negative connotation towards
self-publishing and kind of the cachet
the negative cachet is kind of flipped
it's become more of a positive so that's
a good thing I think it's whatever is
right for you sure sure okay I know I
think a lot of people are going to are
going to uh you know shouldn't one sec
yeah that no that's great that's him
yeah I think it's what comes up at the
right time so yeah that's it right and
so I think certain people are going to
are going to over index in
self-publishing but I also think that
there's a reason for that
um Brian Kay Gilman want somebody post
to the Amazon link pay attention to that
get in there so Josh thank you so much
mate thank you feel free to send me an
email more about you young man I'd like
to get to know your accident talk to you
soon
Cheers in a hundred years old you feel
like a shark young man I'm like I just
became old and like two minutes
basically a solid sharp young individual
with solid career aspirate what the hell
was that